this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 14 with Echo Charles and me Jocko
willink good evening Echo good evening
so recently on Jordan Peterson and
there were some some comments about it
uh that came out and and look we as I go
through some of those comments on the
YouTube channel we can probably do some
kind of a
uh
an underground podcast about the
comments and just kind of reflect on
them and and respond to some of them and
we could probably do that we've talked
about doing that with some of the other
of our podcast in the past but
there was one there was there's a bunch
of things but there was one that I saw
came up a bunch
so at some point
Jordan asked me
if I wanted peace for my son
and for some reason he focused on my son
I also have daughters as well
and and I said I thought about it for a
second I said yes I want there to be
peace for my son
and and whenever I said that Helix
started talking immediately and I wasn't
done yet and I and and I said
but and he
he started talking and wasn't he was not
like he was being rude I saw some people
like let Jocko finish talking and don't
enter look you got to remember a podcast
is a conversation that's what it is and
so when you're having a conversation you
know you got what you think of something
you want to say you don't want to lose a
font he thought of something and he
started talking and I didn't obviously
make it clear that I had a little bit
more to say and so we we moved on
but I did get that button so people knew
that there was more to the answer
and I just wanted to kind of expand on
that just a little bit
um so of course
I want my kids my son and my daughters
to have
and not just them but my family and
friends and people that I know I want
people to have peace and prosperity of
course right that kind of a
that's kind of obvious
but
but I also know that I want them also to
have struggle
I want them to face adversity
right I think that I think that is also
very obvious and I think there are some
people that in the comments said
the butt was what he wanted to say and
that's kind of true too right it's such
a big butt yeah
that I didn't really need to say
anything else
so there was that aspect to it too but
look if you have everything easy in life
you just get soft and weak right I mean
if why not have your kids in an isolated
insulated reinforced concrete bunker
with filtered air and a supply of food
and water and padded walls where nothing
can ever happen to them right because
that's
what you do and you actually put them on
a calorie restrictive diet so that's the
maximum lifespan and all that stuff like
that if that's what we're gonna do
what are you going to end up with you're
not enough with someone that's
they lived for a long time but do they
really live
do they really live
that's the question so yeah I want
everyone to have peace but at the same
time I think that struggle is good I
think that struggle makes better people
adversity makes you tougher
and that's what the butt was about goes
back to
a little bit goes back to something I
said to Sam Harris about combat and
cancer you know I had said that
he was saying you know you say that that
wait that wasn't a very good Sam Harris
of impersonation was no he said uh he
said
he's he said
you know Jocko you say that
combat is horrible but at the same time
you also have said that it was the best
experience in your life
how do you
reconcile those thoughts so that's what
Sam Harris said to me first attempts so
he he asked me that and I and I said
well it's like someone that has cancer
not not someone it's like some people
that have cancer that when they get
through the cancer they say something
along the lines of it's the best thing
that's happened to me you know I got to
put things in perspective I got to
understand what's truly important in
life and so they actually do take
something away from it in a pop that's
positive but they say I'd never Wishing
on anybody so that's that's what I say
about combat as well so
that's what there are some benefits
do I want peace and happiness for my
family for my friends for the people I
know yes absolutely but
there you go
and with that let's get to some q a
cool little q a
yeah I felt this in when I listened to
that podcast I felt the same thing when
you were like but and I figured I knew
what you're gonna say you know but I
still want to hear that and then you're
and I think you said it like twice where
you're like yeah but like you said I was
trying to get it in there yeah the weird
thing is you can't you can't
recreate what you were going to say at
that moment so now I could plot it out
and I could write a paragraph about it
and I could or make bullet points and
then kind of speak to it but I won't I
can't even go back and like recreate
what I was about to say and the spur of
the moment right but again that's why
that's why podcasts they're a
conversation and you have to put being a
conversation at the top otherwise it's
an interview and I don't want to get
well not that I don't want to get
interviewed I get interviewed a lot but
I would much rather I'm not going to get
interviewed for two and a half hours
which is how long we were talking for an
interview for two hours is
is not a good
it's not it's not what I want to hear
it's not what I want to do I don't want
to get interviewed I want to have a
conversation for two hours and if you
out look you might ask me a question
or say something that makes me talk for
14 minutes straight
but then I just don't want you to move
on to the next question I want you to
respond and say something else and like
that's what I think makes podcasts good
to listen to because it's a re it's
supposed to be a real conversation
you can tell you can tell when you're on
with someone that kind of does podcasts
because
there's you you're gonna let someone
finish you know and you know look
Jordan's been out of the game for a
little bit
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just assistance at
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just assistance at
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground